good morning hank it's monday kirkland
brand ted lasso here to share with you
the good news that it's pizza mist
that's right it's the most magical time
of the year for the next two weeks hank
and i will be making week daily videos
just like it was 2007 all over again to
celebrate pizza and mustaches and
e-commerce it's the 10th annual pizzamas
what and today i will be doing an
unboxing video to show you all of the
amazing things that you can get at
pizzamist.com only for the next two
weeks all of our proceeds go to support
stronger healthcare systems and
impoverished communities it is hard to
say anything serious with this mustache
i saw my neighbor this morning and i
waved hello and they said oh hi
okay we have some limited edition stuff
this year because we couldn't get that
many made so i'll start with that we
have the pizza john candle i'd say that
it smells as much like pizza as i would
ever want a candle to smell we also have
this uh
massive
blanket
oh hello also a blanket featuring the
floral pizza john those are both limited
edition so don't wait as is puzzle john
the 1000 piece pizza john jigsaw puzzle
there's also a pizza john ice tray and a
dice set it's only a matter of time
before somebody invents a pizza john
role playing game where you have to
battle demons and dragons while
navigating the universe using only dice
your imagination in a mustache lastly we
have this beautiful limited edition
tie-dye hoodie alright let's get to the
t-shirts
[Laughter]
live laugh pizza john oh this one is
really cool and just a little bit goth i
love how i have a third eye that's pizza
i think the pizzamas designs just get
better and better we got a nice
long-sleeve baseball jersey here
oh one of my all-time favorite jokes old
man yells at pizza oh this one is great
the pizza john is coming out of the box
as a smell side note i suddenly realized
that after 10 pizza misses there may be
a level of inside jokedness that is very
difficult for new viewers to parse but
don't worry i have the face that pizza
john is based on and i also don't get it
anyway with that noted here's a t-shirt
available only for the next two weeks
that imagines my heaven where pizza can
be picked from the ground like flowers
oh wow
wow i mean these are all like actual
works of art this is phenomenal oh boy
sneezing is never normal i never sneeze
this is truly a work of great and
terrible beauty you know every time i
catch a glimpse of myself i think ted
lasso has done a lot for mustaches but
nobody can do much for this mustache i
feel like with the soccer stuff on i
didn't look like ted lasso but i maybe
looked like a you know like a fred masso
but now
now i just don't look good there's also
a bunch of other stuff at peazmas.com
including this 10th anniversary pizza
john patch it's also pizza john's
scratch and sniff stickers if you've
read the anthopazine reviewed you know
how i love scratch and sniff stickers
and there's also a pizza john pin
subscription you get this pin board and
then over six months you fill it out
with all your toppings oh and of course
how could i have forgotten this
beautiful pizza john winter hat just in
time for all of your wintry needs and
sorry i keep changing clothes i'm just
extremely excited there is this wondrous
10th anniversary pizza john zine where
nerdfighters from all around the world
attempted to draw pizza john from memory
it's amazing every year the folks at
dftba and the designers in nerdfighteria
just astonish me i am astonished how did
this happen how did something that
valerie designed all those years ago
turn into
this i don't know but i am so so
grateful again pizzamas.com only for the
next two weeks lots of limited edition
stuff all our profits go to charity hank
i will see you tomorrow